curso muy esperado el de Úrsula
thunderleyen en estrasburgo en la sede
del parlamento europeo posiblemente el
más importante desde que ostentara el
cargo que ha estado muy marcado por la
guerra en Ucrania como comentabas y
sobre todo sus consecuencias estos
altísimos precios de la energía que se
están viviendo en la Unión Europea por
ello ha arrancado primero con las
medidas urgentes principalmente la de
aplicar una tasa a las empresas
energéticas de combustibles fósiles y
también poner límites a los beneficios
de las compañías que generan
que generan energía renovables se espera
como comentabas el poder recaudar
140.000 millones de euros con este
dinero se podrá ayudar a las familias
pero también a las empresas que ahora
mismo tienen verdaderos problemas para
poder pagar las facturas de la
electricidad también ha recordado la
importancia de reducir también al
consumo eléctrico para que así bajen los
precios de está previsto que la comisión
europea proponga a los países que
ahorren un 10% el consumo de
Electricidad y todo con la vista puesta
para poner fin de una vez por todas la
dependencia energética de Rusia de hecho
Wonderland ha recordado que en estos
seis meses desde que empezó la guerra en
Ucrania se ha reducido la importación de
gas de un 40 a un 9%. Esther hablemos
ahora también de algo muy importante el
apoyo a Ucrania en esta guerra en esta
invasión rusa recordamos también que
estuvo allí en el parlamento europeo la
esposa del presidente celena
su discurso con los colores de la
bandera de ucraniana chaqueta amarilla
también camisa azul acompañada de la
primera dama olena ha dicho y ha pedido
a los ciudadanos europeos que no
desfallezcan y que sigan apoyando con
solidaridad a Ucrania especialmente en
los momentos tan duros con altísima
inflación Y estos precios de la energía
consecuencia principalmente de esta
invasión de Ucrania ya ha insistido las
sanciones contra Rusia están para
quedarse y porque no es momento de
apaciguar a Rusia el régimen de Putin ha
asegurado wonderline va a fracasar en su
intento de invadir a Ucrania y de
dividir a Europa precisamente y ya
empieza a viajar vonderley en hacia kiev
para hablar de nuevas medidas al
presidente ucraniano por Vladimir
zelersky es la tercera vez que viaja
wonderley en el país